Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they just
dropped the first teaser trailer for the
Godzilla vs Kong Sequel and it's called Godzilla
X Kong the new Empire Godzilla and Kong will be
teaming up in this one against a new villain who
they also tease in the trailer I'll explain who
that is there are a lot of good theories like no
it's not lanky Kong that would be bold after the
Super Mario Brothers movie like oh wow one of
the other Kongs but if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll do a movie ticket giveaway when
it gets closer to coming out we're actually doing
one for Guardians of the Galaxy 3 this week too
so I'll name a new winner later in the video the
biggest thing in this new trailer is the actual
team up confirming what everyone assumed after
Godzilla vs Kong and them ending in the hollow
Earth also even though the title of the movie was
Godzilla vs Kong essentially they teamed up at the
end of the movie to defeat Mechagodzilla
so they already started working together
yeah but it's not like they're super best friends
like they kind of both went their separate ways at
the end of the movie like okay we're cool we're
not gonna try and kill each other it's a little
tense between them it's kind of like Vin Diesel
in the Rock like you can't put them in the same
room for too long or they will start duking it
out but there are other worse people out there
thus the idea with this other new Titan villain
that they have to team up to destroy the rest of
the title though Godzilla X Kong the new Empire
is partially a reference to this new place the
hollow Earth that they just moved Kong to at the
end of the last movie it's a new Empire full of
all kinds of Titan history that they've slowly
started to explore and reveal in Easter eggs
and details and all the monster verse movies so
far like they've only just started to do hollow
Earth stuff is where most of the Titans came
from the ones that were from planet Earth their
couple Titans in the monster verse that come
from other planets I'll talk about them in a
second but it's where all of Kong and Godzilla's
ancestors came from so when you see the bones of
other Godzilla creatures other large Apes skulls
especially in the trailer too that's a reference
to their ancestor in the trailer you see them
tease that other primate Titan on the throne
similar to Kong's ancient throne in the hollow
Earth with the bones of many Titans in front of
it as well as the bones of Kong and Godzilla
creatures but it's meant to be a reference
to this primate Titan or its ancestors killing
the ancestors of Godzilla in Kong before their
ancestors left the hollow Earth because remember
both of their ancestors had been on the surface
of the Earth for a long time it's just an idea
this whole cycle of dominance inside the hollow
Earth that's been going on since it became a thing
since the birth of all Titans that lived on planet
Earth all the Titans that lived there fighting
to be king of all monsters but during Godzilla
king of monsters even going back to the dawn
of humanity we saw that Godzilla's ancestors
had been worshiped as Gods other Titans had been
worshiped by the people of Earth on the surface
as Gods Kong's ancestors had moved to Skull Island
for a long time so there had been Titans walking
around on the planet's surface for a long time we
only saw some of the other Titan species inside
the hollow Earth like they just teased it during
the last movie but we meet one of the other kings
of all the Titans in the trailer here I think
the whole idea is that at some point Kong's
ancestors in Godzilla's ancestors moved to the
surface sort of leaving this power vacuum like
we saw the Kong throne in the hollow Earth
but it looks like it'd been vacant for a long
long time power abhors the vacuum especially when
you're talking about Titans so this other primate
Titan or his ancestors probably sees control
of all the other Titans down there and based on
his reddish fur his blue eyes super lanky arms
I'd say this is a totally new orangutan Titan
that isn't from the Canon from the previous
monster verse I am the king of the badalog
call me Louie I couldn't find any history on
them doing an orangutan Titan before or even in
the classic Toho films so I think he's meant
to be totally original and they're not jumping
straight to destroya like which other Titans
in the monster verse would be powerful enough
to require Kong and Godzilla to team out together
to defeat them the list isn't that long like you
could do mecha Kong we just did Mechagodzilla but
clearly the monster verse movies just started to
take off like Godzilla versus Kong did pretty
well so they haven't got to the point where
they're ready for like an end game Titan yet and
they only just started to explore the hollow Earth
and speaking of Titans like destroya from other
planets we just did another alien Titan from
another planet King Ghidorah but the whole idea
with the plot of all the monster verse movies is
that the story is based on the consequences from
the previous movie like the real main villain in
Godzilla vs Kong was Mechagodzilla and Apex the
evil Corporation used one of King ghidorah's
heads from Godzilla king of monsters that they'd
salvaged after the events of that movie to create
Mechagodzilla I think the idea now heading into
Godzilla x-con is that Monarch went down into the
hollow Earth set up a station for research there
and started to explore more and Kong moved in and
because he's one of the dominant Titans he started
to take more territory and eventually he winds up
running into this other King level Titan this is
their Apex level Titan and suddenly it's like the
Rock and Vin Diesel running into each other at
the gym like dude dude what are you gonna do even
though the whole idea on all the monster verse
movies is that Godzilla is supposed to be king
of all monsters the idea is that the current
Godzilla has been living above the surface for
a long time just hidden same thing with Kong so
this other orangutan Titan and his ancestors had
been ruling the hollow Earth all these other
many hidden Titans that we've just started to
get teasers for so this is the orangutan Titan
sounds like he commands an army of other Titans
they kind of tease this whole Grand history
like this ancient history for the Kong race
in Godzilla's race in the past couple of movies so
I think we'll also learn more history behind the
Titans in the next one too but essentially that
makes this a hollow Earth movie which I think we
all predicted like oh wow this is giant explorable
space here they just started to tease all these
other huge Titan characters of course they want
to do a movie about those characters the idea is
that they're building towards another three-way
fight like we saw at the end of Godzilla versus
Kong where you have Godzilla and Kong thrashing
the hell out of this new orangutan Titan like they
did with Mechagodzilla and they want that fight to
be interesting so I think that's why they picked
an orangutan just based on its physical features
the way that an orangutan would fight a giant
gorilla Titan in a Titan like Godzilla with their
abilities you notice how long the orangutan's arms
are it's not nearly as powerful as Kong like Kong
is probably the strongest Titan next to Godzilla
but he's more of a brawler the orangutan Titan
would be way quicker and way more agile able to
escape or to keep Kong far enough away so that he
couldn't get him in a bear hug and the whole idea
with Godzilla is that most of their attacks are
area of effect or range DPS like obviously tail
very powerful big tail swipes very sharp claws
very sharp teeth but it doesn't move that fast
and its main attacks like the atomic breath has
a charge up period in a cool down period so the
orangutan would be able to dodge it pretty
easily like you have to be pretty big slow
and stand still in order to get hit by Godzilla's
Atomic breath in Godzilla's area of effect attacks
are mostly energy based his fire form for instance
fire area of attack very powerful but has a longer
charge up period and requires that it be near
maximum radioactive charge like it has to be
full chunky Godzilla full of radioactive energy so
they wanted to pick a Titan villain that wouldn't
be super weak to their Collective main attacks
right off the bat but I think the whole idea here
is that if Godzilla doesn't also move back to the
hollow Earth then Kong will become the new king
of Titans inside the hollow Earth like the new
king of the hollow Earth while Godzilla is king
of monsters on the planet's surface the official
synopsis that they release just reads pitting the
almighty Kong in the Fearsome Godzilla against
a colossal undiscovered threat hidden within our
world in the hollow Earth challenging their very
existence and our own the Epic new film will delve
further into the histories of these Titans like
we'll get more Titan history like I said their
Origins and the mysteries of Skull Island and
Beyond while uncovering the Mythic battle that
helped Forge these extraordinary beings and tied
them to humankind forever my early theory is that
they'll uncover the history of how Kong and
Godzilla's ancestors came to be worshiped by
humanity and came to be their protectors like they
protected them from the more dangerous Titans like
this orangutan race some of the characters will
come back from the last movie like Rebecca Hall's
Eileen Andrews who's one of the researchers
working for monarchs studying Kong Brian Tyree
henries Bernie Hayes who was an apex employee
and ran that Titan podcast Dan Stevens is one of
the new main characters it doesn't say who he is
playing he might be a new Titan researcher working
for Monarch or studying the hollow Earth in follow
Chen who most of you will probably remember is
shangshi's younger sister in the Marvel movies it
doesn't say who she's playing either maybe another
Monarch employee legendary is still doing the
monsterverse TV show with apple that's a totally
different thing but said in the same universe they
haven't said much about that recently or where it
fits in the timeline of the monster verse movies
it'll follow Monarch probably some new Titans in
addition to Godzilla and Kong they did say
that Godzilla and Kong would figure into the
series there were also a lot of rumors about them
doing son of Kong in the new movies I don't know
if that's happening or if it was just a rumor but
they're basically building their way up the ladder
bigger and badder tightens into their own version
of a Monster vs Avengers end game level event
that's probably when they would do a Titan light
destroy from the Canon that's like the last Titan
you would do in the very final movie The Thanos of
all Titans the movies coming out around this time
next year so we'll probably get a full trailer
later this year of course I'll do more videos
when we get more footage everyone posts all your
theories about what's going on the main villain
and what's going on with Kong and Godzilla the
other Titans in the comments below congratulations
all Abbasi 97 you're the giveaway winner from my
Guardians of the Galaxy giveaway email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for my brand new
Mandalorian season 4 teaser video and click here
for my full Mandalorian season 3 episode 8 finale
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you in the next one!